from cnr.com Tucker Carlson confirms
interview with Vladimir Putin it's our
job our duty is to inform people and
apparently he now wants to interview
zalinsky as well a lot of speculation
because Tucker Carlson was seen uh
flying to Moscow and uh of course
everybody thought this is going to be
the Putin interview apparently he was
advised by the US government not to do
it but uh ladies and gentlemen I really
I look at this stuff and I'm like the
machine is
failing that's just it they can't stop
Tucker they tried to stop him but the
internet has given people an opportunity
to build up their own platforms with
their own voices and allow us to
actually communicate in ways that could
end War because I think when people hear
what Putin has to say if Tucker Carlson
does this right and he can do it wrong
if he does it right I think it can
actually help simmer down tensions that
are pushing us towards a World War II
scenario I like it yeah hope hopefully
my concern is that if Tucker doesn't ask
hard questions it will be viewed as as a
puff
piece yeah yeah and people are going to
make that argument regardless yeah the
Russia Russia Russia but there are
there's an American journalist in
detained in Russia currently yes yeah do
do we know his name is is it uh Evan
Evan right right right let me get his
name I can't remember his last name I
feel bad about that but I do remember
Gonzalo lra who was in Ukraine Evan uh
gers
Wall Street Journal reporter Wall Street
Journal may be uh not
necessarily like populist right but
they're not far left and so they've got
a reporter currently detained in Russia
if Tucker Carlson presses Putin on this
reporter and why he's being held or even
gets him released and returned then that
that will be seen as a tremendous peace
effort and substantially more legitimate
however I think the interview probably
already happened so at this point you
know we we will see what this what this
becomes I bet he's back in America
before he or he was back in the US
before he put that stuff out well people
are people in public saw him so they
knew he was there when he was there I
mean let's be real the state department
knew he was there before he went oh
yeah but I think this would be uh this
is Wall Street journals Evan gershkovich
atted Russia in March 2023 this reporter
was arrested in Russia while on a
reporting trip and uh many people been
calling for his release this has been
it's been almost a year now and so I
don't know the circumstances I really
don't and there are challenges to that
because what was he doing who was he in
contact with for all we know this guy
was actually trying to assist Ukraine or
whatever but if Tucker presses him on
issues like this it'll be seen as more
than just commentary my concern is that
Tucker's interview will end up just
being like so what do you think about
this so what do you think about that and
then Putin just says oh this oh that
it's like we knew those opinions already
yeah yeah think oh sorry I no I was
going to say I think it's CRA like
they're going to try and just stop is
for him to humanize him at all because a
lot of people a lot of Tucker um like
his interviews in general humanize
people a lot I think that's like the one
thing they don't want to have happen at
all like they can't stand for this
person they person they been trying to
make Hitler be humanized you know yeah
so uh Natalie F daneli says just
checking in on the left and they're not
okay so here's a funny image it's Tucker
Carlson wearing a Russian hat you know
what's really funny about this image it
looks like George Bush Jr no uh it was
that everyone's favorite press secretary
had a similar hat saki J saki that's
right she had her pink little Kami hat
and their Tucker never wore that she did
y these people are insane Chattanooga
Times Free Press here's one the newest
Soviet hero and there's uh Tucker but I
I think some of these are old I think
they're just you know Russian dressing
haha and and Tucker is putting on a they
cannot me these are definitely old
because it says Fox on the microphone he
hasn't been there for some time Swanson
turkey Carlson Frozen Frozen Russian
asset like that one's not even funny the
internet they don't know how to meme
anyone with the pencil can those are
probably all old though because they all
have him at Fox News and he's not there
anymore this is great I had I've been
wanting to interview Putin for a long
time I wanted to go there with Lex
Freeman a long time ago I was like I
just had a vision like I was laying in
bed like I have to do this it has to
happen because it's similar like I think
that the the the message of why there's
war has been obus skated why I don't
know how does how is his English Putin I
don't know he can speak a little yeah uh
it'd be great if he gives the interview
in English dude it' be so good it's part
of what makes um but he can't articulate
himself as a as as um um intricately in
in a second language what were you say
well what were you you were you said
that you were unsure of why why the war
was going on I think a lot of people
don't know what the hell is happening
they're like does Putin wanted to take
over Europe that they think that that's
what's happening I thought that he
wanted that trade port in sasta pole and
they're trying to secure land bridges
like East 105 and East 97 those freeways
that go down into the Crimea across the
northern so they have to take that land
and they haven't really Advanced much
further than that it doesn't look like
they want anything other than
Mediterranean Sea
access and that's not really a cass's
belly to throw our men and women add a a
Bo a meat grinder and the poor
ukrainians fund a meat grinder for those
people like I don't think so and if they
want a new world order man Russia and
the United States can collaborate and
make that happen we have a very very
important uh note contextual update on
the uh the mayorcas impeachment Blake
Moore off the hook Blake Moore voted to
impeach mayorcas only changed his vote
because they needed a procedural reason
to refile next week okay so Blake MO is
in favor of impeaching May orcus the
Republicans said it I guess it can't be
a tie we need a reason to refile so
change your vote he said okay so
apologies margorie Taylor green tweeted
that out saying the three no votes were
Mike Gallagher Tom mcclintic and Ken
Buck Blake Moore is actually helping
them refile because of the other three
so in fact if anything donate more to
that guy for uh for for for standing up
so apologies more I appreciate that yeah
good on you Blake exactly anyway uh
cited numerous interviews the corporate
press is held with Ukrainian President
Vladimir zinsky describing them as
fawning pep sessions specifically
designed to amplify zelinsky's demand
that the US enter more deeply into a war
in Eastern Europe and pay for it that is
not journalism it is government
propaganda of the ugliest kind the kind
that kills people actually that actually
he didn't he didn't actually say I added
that because it should have been there
anyway but uh he's right he's right and
I and I do I mean look I look at what's
going going going on now politically and
I really do feel like we have a strong
opportunity to end this war machine at
least in some capacity Trump's far from
perfect but shout out to Dave Smith when
he came on the show and even he was like
I yes like Trump was way better than
these other presidents on foreign policy
like and we and we we like those things
like it's not we don't like what he did
we like the things he didn't do that
every other president did and I'm like
we're winning the Libertarians we're
getting some of them and that's good
enough now with moves like this they
cannot silence us I don't want to go to
war Vladimir Putin invading Ukraine has
nothing to do with me or you or anyone
in the United States it is garbage
nonsense and that's it we don't care
about any of these other conflicts
around the world some some country
invaded some other country and and and
what do we say nothing but when the US
is trying to invade and do these things
did you hear what Chuck Chuck Schumer
said the other day when he was saying
that like we may be at war in Eastern
Europe he said if we lose this war and I
said excuse me we lose this War I didn't
realize you thought we were in it I mean
I've been saying it's us many of those
who aren't stupid knew it was us but now
you have the gall to publicly State we
are fighting this war Chuck Schumer just
said on TV the US is at war with
Russia well that's insane bulldo
DC my and the war machine I like the
sound of that except my concern is
liberal economic order is has the war
machine it's the military industrial
complex Bo you know locki these big
Contracting comp corporations if it
transitions to a New World Order that's
like more of a corporate governance are
they going to own the war machine then
is it going to be corporations that own
lock heat and
boing instead of them being subservient
to the American government they're
already owned by corporations yeah
they're fasly tied in with the US
government but are they going to like
disperse the span with the US government
and then go to some corporate fascist
collusion and then it'll be like
governed from Switzerland and we'll just
become Global ser to this corporate
monster I'm not sure what you're talking
about the New World Order they want to
corporatize governance I understand that
but I'm not I don't I'm not
understanding the actual structure
you're talking about or trying my
concern is that right now the American
government is sort of in control of the
of the war machine or the war machines
in control of the American government
but they have a collusive state of being
and we're benefiting from that as
Americans in a way in a big big big way
a lot of other people are suffering
tremendously as a result so if they
transition that and it's no longer the
American government that is tied up with
this war machine would it then just be
corporations that are totally in control
no free speech I they wanted to be a lot
more like China yeah so then in that if
that's the case i' I'd rather not shut
down the liberal economic order I mean
maybe I know the world wants that and I
don't like 700 American military bases
all over Earth and bombing trade routes
and and waterways and to keep keep
American Steel flowing but like
the I see two paths I see technocratic
fascism or or like militaristic fascism
I don't know what's if there's a third
way I'd like to I'd like to see it
that's my problem you don't see a third
way either like it be decentralized
governance of some sort no there's no
there's no perfect system yeah there's
just look Communism works perfectly and
this is a fact that it's time everyone
recognized it works perfectly after you
kill anyone who dare oppose you
that's the issue when when when when
everyone is ideologically homogenized
your system works because everyone
expects what they get if you're starving
to death that's the world we live in
like Harry Tubman said I freed many
slaves I would have freed many more If
Only They knew they were slaves so
whatever system you have if you
eliminate dissent the system operates is
it the best system well it depends on
what your definition of best is so if
you look at um parliamentary govern
governance Democratic uh in you know
constitutional republics or whatever I
think what we have in the United States
is the best we can come up with but you
will still get power coalescing which
leads to corruption that needs to be
accounted for and held
accountable but so long as everyone
agrees ideologically government
governance is it doesn't matter if
everyone on the planet was as religious
as Sheamus cogin you'd have World Peace
you would have no conflict no crisis
there would be no war because they would
all be ideologically homogenized it's
not because Sheamus is the nicest person
in the world or because his religion is
correct he may argue that but it's
because they all completely agree on
their moral structures and Foundations
as to what they should or should not do
which means no one would steal no one
would murder if someone did they would
all agree like that was a mistake even
the person who did it would be like I
can't believe I did it you're right I
was wrong the problem is when people
disagree on what they should be allowed
to do and we're trying to find that
balance yeah had resource
distribution um right but if everyone
was ideologically homogenized resource
distribution would not be an issue they
would all completely agree someone would
say well we need food in this city
unfortunately the only food available is
by those people and they've grown it
themselves and they're going to keep it
understood it's theirs there that's it
the the issue is there are people who
believe I I should be allowed to steal
from you because I'm more important than
you and then there's a guy who says I
grew this food it's mine you can't take
it from me I will defend it by force cuz
I don't want to die yeah there's the
people of like kindness and compassion
are the basis of reality and then
there's the people that are like might
makes right and those are the people
that tend to run things envious now to
be fair what I'm saying only works with
a moral Foundation if there were people
with no morals they could all completely
agree it's my right to take it and you
get nothing but chaos War famine you
know Murder I'm I'm talking
about I I think it's fair to say like
Christianity if people followed those
tenants
the way like again shout to Sheamus
kogin the way he does Faithfully
executing these these beliefs and these
good morals then the there'd be world
pece at least for a time you you that's
until people start to develop counter
morals and then fight sure it's entirely
possible that uh you know what I'm going
to say this it is it is completely
factual for a time is the correct
response the United States was a
Christian Nation it had some bad things
in it worked towards improving was very
Toler of evil let the marxists come into
their institutions and now Christianity
is being purged yeah that's true what do
you guys think is like the best or like
the least what's the off-ramp Phil
what's the best path forward because if
we don't want the liberal economic Order
anymore why because it's the military
bases all over Earth are suppressing and
annihilating our neighbors and causing
massive hatred and blowback towards
American citizens I don't believe I
reject the idea that the liberal
economic order needs military bases all
over the world I think that the military
bases all over the world are simply or
are not simply but are mostly there to
deter the expansion of nuclear weapons
and I think that the whether or not you
you think that's the right thing to do
or not that's what I believe the
military bases are all over the world
for it was the the US saying look we'll
put you a military base in your country
that way if anyone invades your country
they risk harming the United States and
we have nuclear weapons so that means
you don't need nuclear weapons that's
the whole post World War II World Order
is is that order there is there was the
Warsaw Pact which are the Russians and
then there was the United States and
NATO and the US was like look we don't
want to have every country in NATO to
have their own nuclear Arsenal so we
will put nuclear weapons in these
countries that are likely to be overrun
in Europe should the Russians decide
that they're or should the Warsaw pack
decided they're going to run tanks over
Poland and it prevented World War II
massive stability relative stability on
Earth of Nations I mean what's that
prevented it seems to have prevented
World War III as we no Total War
prevented a nuclear exchange when the
Soviet Union existed maybe it's better
that we don't create a new world order
that we just keep the liberal economic
order and people you know get get used
to the American military bases but if
there's a communist if there's a a
Russian military base in Florida I'd be
pretty nervous but we just talked we
just literally literally just said that
the military bases don't have anything
to do with the liberal economic order
the military bases have to do with the
fact that they that we don't want
nuclear prolifer proliferation but it's
also like and buy our oil and US Dollars
by the way if you want this deal as well
well not not necessarily because because
the you there are other reasons to have
the US dollar part of the reason why we
do like foreign aid right and I'm
against all foreign aid right but part
of the reason we do it is so that way
other countries have dollars so that way
they'll spend the dollars which also
gives value to the dollar the value of
the dollar comes from the fact that
there's a demand for taxes it does come
from the fact that we have a strong
military and we can we can use military
force but it comes from a bunch of
different places now granted none of
those places are backed by anything of
value but it doesn't mean that like the
the liberal economic order is in is
inherently connected with military bases
all over the U or all over the world
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net